David Whalen: The liberal arts are those disciplines
the knowledge which of is necessary to lead
a completely humane life. It's probably best
to describe a liberal education as an education
in things worth knowing inherently, things
that a human life is rendered somewhat incomplete,
somewhat undeveloped, somewhat unfulfilled
by not knowing. Just as health is the proper
good state and condition of the body, so a
disciplined, informed, robust understanding
of reality is the proper state or condition
of the human mind.
The point is to lead rich human lives, and
humans naturally desire the good, they naturally
desire the true, and they naturally desire
the beautiful. We're asking what do people
need to know, and let's require them to know
it. About half one's time here is spent in
what we call the core curriculum. That will
include a study of literature, a study of
history, a study of the Constitution and politics.
It will include the study of biology and mathematics
and chemistry and physics. It will include
the study of fine arts and social sciences
like sociology or psychology or economics.
It's rich and full, as is your own intellectual
nature. Let's bring those two together. That's
a Hillsdale College liberal education.